all right Charisma yeah Charisma uh
where you from originally where'd you
grow up I'm from Las Vegas Nevada you're
from Vegas yep that's that's where you
were born born and raised and that's
you're still based there yeah you're
just out here on Figaro Street yeah just
testing the waters just uh trying a
different Market yeah what was your
family like growing up um not the
greatest uh my parents were constantly
fighting and uh they're both addicts so
my dad's like a raging alcoholic and my
mom's a raging meth head and that
doesn't really mix um so by the time
like they got divorced when I was 12 it
was like finally you know like I'll
actually get some sleep for
once um and then when they got divorced
my mom dipped out to New Mexico and my
dad like is just so like absent uh he
just got me my sister an
apartment pretty much just like got us
an apartment and every now and then he
would like drop off money he was just
never there and so you guys raised
yourself yeah your older sister or
younger sister uh she's two years older
than me but I love her to
death but she's definitely like we're
like Fire and Ice you know complete
opposites sisters yeah what was the what
would you say is the roughest part of
your childhood um my best friend was
murdered uh when I was 13 on the second
last day of seventh grade um she was at
one of her friend's house cuz she lived
on like the opposite end of town for
me
um yeah she's at her friend's house
and uh she was walking
away and I guess the girl was playing
with her dad's gun and it unloaded into
her stomach or like Shot Through My Best
Friend's stomach
and you know I wasn't there but like
that girl really played like a very big
part in my childhood and like upcoming
and cuz she was like the blonde like
cheerleader president of the student
council flag football girl and I was
just like the nerdy the only girl in
like the gifted and talented program
like I was like really smart but kind of
like
weird like there's something off about
me did you finish High School yes I
actually finished high school in 2017
when I supposed to be out in 2018 so I
did a year early how old are you now 23
years old 23 mhm how did you first get
introduced to this lifestyle um through
just toxic relationships with men
honestly
um yeah it's just the men that like I go
for always end up introducing me to
another guy who knows a guy who knows a
guy and you know and so you run into a
pimp yeah um I wouldn't say like I have
a pimp there's just a lot of guys that
uh if they know that you're working
they'll try to like stay by you until
like you make the money and break bread
break bread but me and red like me and
my girlfriend pretty much just work for
ourselves we don't let do you keep all
your
money I
mean money is such like profound thing
to me because I'm always like abundant
like wherever I'm at I always have what
I need I know like you know God got me
I'm really strong in my faith always so
I'd rather break red
than you know start a problem so you're
paying guys to protect you or whatever
yeah cuz they have my back so you know
take care of me and I'll take care of
you it's no babgy I love being generous
and but
and do in Vegas do you live in a do you
have an apartment or do you stay in a
motel yeah I stay in motels like
weeklys um I haven't had an apartment
since
um 6 months ago honestly like 6 months
ago with my mom actually she took off
with my son and um it really it really
[__] me out
um we got into a fight because she
started she relapsed and started doing
math again because of my
ex-boyfriend who thought that would be a
good idea to give her some math and uh
we just kept fighting and fighting and
fighting and it got like physical and
she like I left for two days so I
wouldn't get more physical with her came
back home
and my apartment has
been ran through it wasn't even 48 Hours
my baby daddy and my ex-boyfriend came
together and decided you know we're
going to drill through the locks and
make this abando and there was just a
bunch of like bums like with my stuff in
my
bags packing my whole life away my whole
life was just in these bags and um there
was a paper that said my mom father was
trining her against
me so you know at that point I just
looked at all this like material things
and was like you know what guys like I'm
going to let you like go through each
bag one by one and I'm going let you
keep most of this [__] but you know
there are like some things like
sentimental things that like I would
like to keep and sure enough these
[__] went through each bag and
I really let them keep about 90% because
you know I don't have my son I and that
was really like my son was my Saving
Grace um when like I looked at my son I
knew like this life had a purpose for me
I knew I I know what loveing life is you
know and for her to take that away from
me really hurt how old is he he's two
and a half now August 15th and the
father is where the streets in Las Vegas
addicted to
fentanyl um I actually went looking for
him about a week ago and I asked some
guy at the gas station like have you
seen Trevor have you seen him and
they're like oh well he's usually in the
alley and it's funny because
um when I first like went to the streets
I was living in an alley on like Fremont
in Las
Vegas Fremont
Street what what is your drug uh crack I
only smoke crack
now I actually just got off of Fentanyl
and blues so I'm really proud about that
but I'm just cracking
now
and you're working the streets in Vegas
or Internet um yeah like ads it's more
internet and whatever my girlfriend like
she goes out on the streets and you know
she feels it out because there's only
like so much I'm comfortable doing I'm
more of like an internet or like
networking like you know like I go on
like actual like dates and like hang out
and you know just smoke and get paid how
do you feel about this lifestyle how
does it you emotionally it's really
heavy like on my emotional state um I've
always had mental health problems
but um yeah it's just a really heavy
thing to deal
with these guys
are really cold the streets are just so
cold that's the best way I can put it is
cold um but what kind what kind of guys
are typically your your clients they're
they're married guys they guys that are
just in town to party um yeah it's
usually like
married men like big trucks like big
pickup trucks um just being dirty dogs
they're usually drunk or yeah always
drunk always smell like alcohol
and what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work we learned about
men um see men differently because of
what you've
seen yeah I'm I'm honestly a man hater
like men just like are not [__] to me
that's why I got with my girlfriend red
because she's just such a cool ass
[__] chick
she's a cool woman do so I mean do you
hate the guys that you're
servicing um yeah about
about 75% of the time
um yeah but I mean I have like a fiance
like who's in
prison he used to be a pimp but he
actually like saved me he found me on
Las B Boulevard in
Fremont and was like you know like we're
not going to live like this like we're
going to have like a normal life
together like we're on the streets for a
little bit but we're going to be all
right and that's Chicago my fuing that's
my baby he's facing organized crime and
theft and burglary in Las
Vegas but
and how are you guys going to support
yourselves by by you doing what you're
doing um I'm
hoping I can just do this
until one day I just stack up another
money to go to school or land in some
kind of like stable housing to get back
on my feet because everything like the
rug was just ripped completely out from
under me but I know if I like stay
strong in my faith then you know God
will put me into the right place at the
right
time and yeah I'll make it out and I
want to do like nails and hair and like
you know all that basic [__] [__] the
basic white girl [__] do you uh do you
have any regrets in your life a lot a
lot what are what are some of your
regrets the biggest regret I have is
ever smoking anything off of foil like
free
basing CU that led to cuz it's not that
I necessarily regret drugs it's like the
way I do drugs
and
um mostly like not standing up for
myself
or yeah standing up for myself or using
my voice when I could have or um just
not do not trusting my gut you know and
it's crazy because one of my teachers in
elementary school on a test she saw that
like I erased an answer and circled a
different one and the one I erased was
the right answer and she put a little
note on there like always go with your
first guess and that's really stuck with
me because like you know what if I would
have just like went with like my first
reaction or like you know went with my
you know my first guess my first choice
then you know probably would have got it
right
but I live for the chaotic lifestyle I
guess yeah you've had bad things happen
to you yeah I've been
like sexually assaulted I've been raped
I've been drugged I've been actually
kidnapped held
Ransom
and just you know ultimately betrayed
betrayed by my mother betrayed by my
father um I was kicked out on my 18th
birthday and uh my dad pretty much like
he knew like I was having to like sleep
with men for like a place to stay and he
didn't like he didn't care he would just
sit there and be like well like you
better figure it out cuz I'm getting
tired it's getting late I have to go
home and you're not going to my house so
you better figure it out and that was
all just because I was with like a drug
dealing piece of
[__] um that I refused to you know stick
up for myself and because you know this
guy had made me so dependent on Xanax
that was like my first thing um and this
guy just fed my addiction so you know
and I felt like my boyfriend was there
for me more than my dad was so why would
I choose my own father over my boyfriend
who literally you know gives me
everything I need and when does your
current boyfriend get out of prison um
he's still going to trial right
now so oh so he is waiting for his
verdict
mhm yeah but he already has
priors of
burglary uh he's only 31 and he spent 10
years like
incarcerated did you say your your
choice in men is uh felons part of the
problem yeah problem children felons uh
tatted white boys pretty much is my type
yeah where where do you see yourself in
five years
um I hope that like I'm in school or
like finished
cool um ultimately I would just like to
be able to be my son's life
again and that's all like I could really
ask for yeah do you get depressed
sometimes living this life yeah a lot
it's got to be hard
woman yeah but you know can't like let
it show you just kind of got to Thug it
out you got to be tough yeah got to be
as hard as you are strong you know and
sometimes you don't really have a choice
but to just walk
what do you think people don't
understand about women that do this kind
of work um it could be anyone uh
honestly a year ago I talked so much
[__] about girls like this and oh like
people living in tents and oh like
they're good for nothing how could they
let that happen
and uh now here I am with nothing
nothing to show
and it could it could really be anyone
you know and so stay humble or else God
will do it for you that's for sure how
much money would you make a night in
Vegas
um I shoot for like at least ,000 you
know
um and usually it's at least like $500 a
client so not bad you you guys will go
to a hotel room or yeah we tell them
that they have to have a hotel room if
they want any
service yeah and then if they only want
like a car then that's when they pay
more and more you know cuz they don't
want to get a hotel room or EXC excuses
excuses more money they have to pay us
have you been arrested in Vegas yeah uh
a couple times that's actually where I
met my uh girlfriend red was in City
Jail in 2019 but then I didn't talk to
her for years and sure enough my uh
boyfriend that's in prison right now
Chicago introduce me to
her so or like reintroduce me to her and
it was crazy I was like wait I know you
I know you I remember you uh they called
me Harley Quinn when I was in jail
because I had a heart tattoo that I got
with one of my exes for whatever reason
I got it removed now but yeah and I had
my whole head was just blonde as [__]
like glowing it was so blonde and I'd
have it in like two braids and had a
black eyy so they call me Harley
Quinn and yeah I went to jail the first
time when I was
18 uh it was actually like a couple days
after my 18th birthday because my sister
showed up at the apartment was like uh
you can't be here what are you doing
here and gone to a fight with my
ex-boyfriend and I'm not going to let
her fight my boyfriend so um me and my
sister scrapped it out and I had
pictures on my old iPhone uh of me like
literally sitting there she whooped my
booty but I had a black eye like fat lip
and I ended up getting being the one to
get
arrested but no it's mainly like
domestic violence they were I've had a
couple of those um battery disorderly
conduct um and the most recent one is
what is it
possession um
and burglary with burglar
tools where is your sister now she's
actually in Wheatland California what is
she doing she does lashes okay and she's
living the dream she lives in like 10
acres of like just beautiful grass Hills
and her fiance is like uh renovating
like a double wide trailer to fit her
standards cuz she's this bougie ass
[__] Vegas girl and it's really
beautiful you know cuz my sister has
been through her share of
[__] uh
yeah like she she actually played a part
in like why I started hanging out with
like these like piece of [__] people
because when I was a freshman she was a
senior and um you know it was just like
turn up party drink and xanx were they
really popping at that time so yeah
and when I'm on Xanax like I think
everybody is just like so cool and I'm
so cool and I can get down with anybody
do you feel like your
parents being drug users or alcoholics
can of open the door for your drug use
yeah my mom is the one that gave me my
first Xanax oh really yeah uh and that
was because of my anxiety for my best
friend being killed I didn't really want
to like socialize I wouldn't I would
have a panic attack even pulling up to
school so bad I'd be throwing up and she
was just like tired she so you know she
gave me like a little football and sure
enough like oh this one's good this
one's good and then my sister started
doing them start doing them together and
then we start like selling them
and one thing to
another yeah but yeah my mother
definitely played a big
part Charisma what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life um God is good God is always
good no
matter you know what happens God will
always be
good you believe in God yeah and
he I mean what where does God play a
role in in your situation that you're in
now um he keeps like he watches over me
he keeps me protected and only puts me
around people
that are going to like teach me
something you know whether like it kind
of sucks to have to learn but you know
I'm humble enough to know that I'm like
naive enough to learn I'm always open to
learning you know uh to be taught is a
better word humble enough to be taught
cuz you can be out here and cuz when I
was a teenager that's really what like
got me into a lot of um bad situations
is thinking that I knew what I was doing
um nowadays I don't know [__] like
people ask me something I'm like I don't
know [__] and I most I really don't you
know cuz you can think that you know but
you don't know you know there's always
like there like perception you know like
you don't know all the ins and outs of
things you think you think you do and
then there's always that you know one
thing all right charisma thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
wish you lots of luck out here on in La
thank you be careful out there all right
thank you very
much